je préfère mourir debout que vivre à
genoux ce sont les mots de Stéphane
charbonnier connu sous le nom de Charles
directeur de la publication de Charlie
Hebdo assassiné aujourd'hui victime de
la fusillade qui a fait 12 morts à Paris
dans les locaux du journal satirique 12
morts parmi lesquels volants ski cabus
en cortinus des figures emblématiques
bonsoir un journal particulier ce soir
au regard des événements qui touchent le
pays en attentat terroriste ce sont les
termes employés par le Président de la
République les réactions qui affluent du
monde entier un rassemblement se déroule
notamment ce soir à Paris place de la
République et en ce moment devant les
locaux de Téléfilm 78 symboliquement
c'est également un regroupement qui a
lieu vous le voyez sur ces images c'est
un rassemblement de solidarité et de
soutien à Charlie Hebdo et au-delà à la
liberté d'expression toucher aujourd'hui
7 janvier en tout une centaine de
mobilisations de ce type sont annoncées
à travers le pays nous sommes en ligne
avec Patrice carmouz journaliste vous
travaillez avec la rédaction de
téléfiles bonsoir Patrice
et vous connaissez bien Stéphane
charbonnier le directeur de la rédaction
de Charlie Hebdo 47 ans né à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine dans les
Yvelines comment réagissez-vous
aujourd'hui c'est entre la tristesse et
la colère
j'avais on avait travaillé ensemble
c'était quelqu'un d'abord de plein
d'humour plein c'était un type très
courageux c'est lui quand même qui a
continué malgré les malgré les menaces
malgré les impacts à faire le métier
qu'il croyait de voir ça c'est-à-dire le
métier de liberté et c'est toujours il y
a toujours la tristesse de l'humiliation
j'allais dire quand quand en train de
quitter
liberté donc c'était ce premier
sentiment et puis évidemment après la
colère c'est-à-dire que voilà on peut
pas on peut pas laisser faire on peut
pas faire que cette barbarie l'emporte
sur sur l'intelligence c'est sur la
liberté il faut se défendre il faut il
faut il faut ne pas laisser faire ça
évidemment il y a ce dessin de charme
qui a été publié aujourd'hui 7 janvier
dans le Charlie Hebdo on va voir à
l'écran dans un instant on peut y lire
pas d'attentat en France et la réponse
du terroriste qui est qui est dessiné on
a jusqu'à la fin du mois de janvier pour
présenter ses vœux Charles n'avait pas
peur un des menaces rien ne faisait ne
lui faisait oublier son combat pour la
liberté d'expression
c'est ça c'est à dire que c'est
quelqu'un je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui croyait aussi non l'intelligence des
autres c'est quelqu'un de très
intelligent mais qui croyait aussi dans
l'intelligence des autres et peut-être
que au fond
il sait que peut-être avec avec les mots
avec les dessins avec l'humour on
pouvait peut-être changer les choses
malheureusement
la réalité montre qu'on va pas se
changer les choses parmi les gens qui
sont les plus les plus idiots et les
prix crétins donc les salopards quoi
peut-être que ça a été peut-être façon
erreur mais en même temps c'est fait son
combat son combat c'était la liberté la
liberté d'expression n'était pas
forcément tous d'accord avec lui
toujours d'accord avec lui il avait des
convictions et des exprimer avec avec
son talent et mais avec sa force mais
c'était quelqu'un qui était écrit de
liberté et pour lui et pour les autres
pour vous au-delà de la perte d'un ami
cette attaque ce matin cette attentat ce
sont un attentat terroriste ce sont les
termes utilisés par le Président de la
République c'est une attaque envers
toute une profession la liberté
d'expression plus globalement c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le percevoir je
crois que c'est il faut le percevoir
gravement
on a déjà fait la avec le 11 septembre
et je crois qu'elle s'impose je crois
qu'il y aura un avant et un après comme
il y a eu un avant un après 11 septembre
oui c'est une déclaration de guerre à la
liberté une libération de guerre la
liberté d'expression déclaration de
guerre aussi à
cette façon de vivre c'est la nôtre qui
est celle de nos pays c'est-à-dire de
l'humour de rire de rire de c'était ça
aussi ça vient d'où cette vidéo c'est du
rire et cette c'est des gens qui
voudraient nous paierait chez nous faire
qu'on se taise faire qu'on se taire et
ben c'est c'est contre ça qu'il faut
lutter et donc je crois qu'il y aura un
avant et un après
7 janvier un avant et après attentat
parce que on pourra plus réagir demain
comme on a réalisé jusqu'à présent merci
Patrice d'avoir témoigné ce soir je
rappelle que vous étiez parmi les
proches de charme le directeur de la
rédaction de Charlie Hebdo né dans les
Yvelines à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine qui
figure parmi les 12 victimes de
l'attentat d'aujourd'hui donc nous
déroulons la suite de ce journal un
petit peu particulier ce soir j'aimerais
qu'on voit quelques-unes des une de
Charlie Hebdo et une assez spécifique
caractéristiques qui ont fait la marque
de fabrique de ce journal et peut-être
une couverture une à retenir c'est c'est
celle-ci l'amour plus fort que la haine
c'est peut-être l'image qu'il faut
garder aujourd'hui alors que on le sait
l'attentat a été particulièrement
sanglant et violent va revenir à présent
à la mobilisation l'un des
rassemblements qui se déroule à travers
la France l'un de ses rassemblements se
déroule devant les locaux de tvfils 78
justement organe de presse également
directement bien évidemment de
proportion gardée visée à travers cet
attentat c'est la liberté d'expression
vous entendiez tout à l'heure le
témoignage de Patrice kermous catherine
zolato est dehors avec les personnes qui
se sont regroupées qui se sont
rassemblés pour recueillir quelques-unes
de leurs expressions quelques quelques
témoignages donc les personnes
rassemblées ce soir devant téléfils 78
ce sont donc des citoyens des membres
d'associations il y a Antonin Moulard
qui est pardon étudiant à l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin bonsoir
Antonin
ce soir
c'est spontanément que nous sommes venus
à téléfils ce soir en raison de
l'actualité et de la mort de
l'attentat envers la rédaction de
Charlie Hebdo on vient rendre hommage à
toutes les personnes assassinées
aujourd'hui
pour avoir utilisé la liberté
d'expression et
plus largement à toutes à toutes les
journalistes et toutes les personnes qui
sont mortes pour pour cette exprimé je
pense que il faut pas se laisser
intimider et qu'il est devoir
d'organiser des rassemblements publics
partout pour défendre la liberté
d'expression il faut aussi rendre
hommage aux deux policiers qui étaient
là pour protéger
pour protéger Charb
et
à toute enfin je sais pas qui était dans
ce cette rédaction exactement mais en
tout cas rendre hommage à toutes les
personnes qui sont qui sont mortes
aujourd'hui dans cette attentat
la République tout comme de nombreuses
personnalités politiques ont appelé à
l'unité nationale vous suivez ce
il faut que toutes les personnes même
au-delà de la nation
se rassemblent dans les lieux publics et
défendre le principe universel qui est
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
la presse
d'autres mouvements d'autres
rassemblement vous souhaitez organiser
là on sait que ce soir c'était assez
spontané devant téléfilm alors il y a
rassemblement qui organisé vendredi à
18h30 à la fac à la mezzanine Vauban
donc rendez-vous 18h30 à la mezzanine
Vauban ce vendredi pour des prises de
parole citoyennes et on espère que la
presse locale sera là aussi pour
témoigner de leur métier et de ce que
c'est que le journaliste
pour se rassemblement merci Catherine
vous êtes dehors donc avec les personnes
qui se sont rassemblées je vous le
disais 12 12 victimes plusieurs
journalistes et deux policiers qui
assurent la protection des journalistes
on peut revoir cette photo ou figures
les détinateurs les caricaturistes qui
ont été visés ce matin Wolinski cabus
tignus ou encore Charb ont perdu la vie
on va revoir juste cette photo et
d'ailleurs parmi ces différentes
victimes il y avait kabulles dessinateur
de 76 ans caricaturiste rendu célèbre
notamment par ses passages à la télé il
était en novembre dernier dans les
Yvelines à l'occasion du festival Blues
sur scène ce sont nos confrères
d'Yvelines première qu'il l'avait
rencontrées ils avaient ils venaient de
réaliser une série de dessins loin cette
fois-ci des polémiques
ça c'est des dessins pour et je dis
toujours que faire des dessins pour
c'est plus difficile que de faire des
dessins contre j'ai fait des dessins
souvent contre les politiques quand ils
déconnent à mon avis mais là je cherche
simplement à
à ce que les gens aient envie d'écouter
de la musique sur ces dessins quoi voilà
ça c'est des dessins pour
nos confrères de la télé locale Yvelines
Première les réactions qui continuent à
fumer enflué pardon en cette fin de
journée du monde politique notamment
Pierre Bédié le président du Conseil
général des Yvelines évoque un acte
abject dirigé contre les journalistes et
la liberté d'expression il se dit
horrifié par cette barbarie Valérie
Pécresse député des Yvelines s'est
exprimée sur les réseaux sociaux sur
Twitter et l'écrit mes pensées vont aux
victimes et à leurs proches soutien
total à la rédaction Jean polluchon
président de l'Île-de-France présent en
fin de journée au PC sécurité de la RATP
pour sécuriser les transports apportent
lui aussi sa solidarité à la rédaction
du journal et puis également cette
réaction de Benoît Hamon député des
Yvelines il a travaillé en tant
qu'enseignant avec Bernard Marie ses
économiste tu es lui aussi ce matin dans
les locaux de Charlie Hebdo il parle
d'une immense tristesse les deux hommes
ont collaboré pendant trois ans à Paris
a été la même
sur
leur religion leur absence de religion
peu importe
un crime aussi que cela
le message il est clair c'est la liberté
d'expression
que l'on vise ce sont des journalistes
des caricaturistes qui sont froidement
assassinés
moi je connaissais bien des
connecteurs de Charlie Hebdo qui étaient
professeur répond à l'Université Paris 8
Paris Bernard mariste qui est économiste
qui était économiste et qui a été
lâchement assassiné comme les deux
autres
personnes qui ont perdu la vie
aujourd'hui c'était
un économiste engagé absolument brillant
un excellent pédagogue il a il animait
des débats économiques tous les
vendredis matin sur sur France Inter
c'est un homme de très très grande
qualité il faut y répondre avec à la
fois de la force et de l'unité et se
rassembler tous éviter évidemment les
amalgames ne pas se tromper entre ce qui
défendent une idéologie meurtrière et
ceux qui pratiquent une religion
pacifiquement
les organisations syndicales ne sont pas
en reste la CGT rappelle et salut le
courage de ces hommes et de ses femmes
qui chaque jour chaque semaine malgré
les intimidations et les menaces
défendent la liberté de penser la
liberté d'expression de notre pays le
Secours populaire salut l'engagement au
profit des causes humanitaires et des
journalistes décédés et puis le syndicat
des journalistes rappellent aussi que
les menaces de mort contre la profession
se multiplient hier encore un
journaliste du Monde cette fois-ci a
reçu une quatrième lettre anonyme le SNJ
qui souhaite rencontrer le ministère de
l'Intérieur à ce sujet voyez aussi ces
images de drapeau en berne c'est à
Saint-Cyr l'école on signe de deuil le
maire marque de cette façon son soutien
aux victimes je vous propose de
l'écouter
ces symbolique mais c'est vraiment dire
que on est tous touchés et que il faut
qu'on comprenne tous que la liberté ça
se défend tous les jours et quel que
soit les marques que l'on puisse
exprimer il faut être
compatissant et puis aussi
en accord avec les familles qui ont été
touchées leur exprimer toutes nos
sympathie et leur dire que nous sommes
aussi nous en deuil la Guyancourt
également la municipalité a décidé de
procéder de la même manière au delà de
l'émotion à présent c'est la sécurité
nationale qui est renforcée le plan
Vigipirate dans l'ensemble de
l'Île-de-France est à son niveau le plus
élevé concrètement les cellules de crise
sont activées services de secours force
de l'ordre sont en alerte les contrôles
de personnes renforcées exemple ici dans
le centre commercial Espace
Saint-Quentin à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
au milieu des nombreux clients présents
pour l'ouverture des soldes de plus en
plus de policiers
on a reçu un appel à partir de à peu
près 12h30 donc un format de la hausse
de du plan Vigipirate et nous demandons
de mettre en place des mesures adaptées
et notamment de renforcer notre sécurité
donc de manière immédiate on a renforcé
à chaque entrée avec un contrôle
systématique des sacs un contrôle visuel
pour vérifier chaque sac
c'est surtout donc de rassurer le client
de vérifier que tout se passe bien
d'être vigilant sur
individu suspect colis suspect de toute
façon le plan Vigipirate était déjà en
place nous on avait déjà renforcé on va
dire au mois de décembre là on l'a
intensifié avec un contrôle à chaque
entrée on a par ailleurs informé
l'ensemble de nos commerçants j'étais
sur le terrain avec toutes mes équipes
pour informer les commerçants alors même
que certains n'étaient même pas au
courant que ce matin il y avait eu un
attentat donc on a aussi expliqué aux
gens le pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'était
passé pour suite à cette hausse du
niveau et là donc moi je suis en ligne
aussi bien avec la mairie le
commissariat la direction de
l'hypermarché pour faire en sorte que on
ait des meilleures infos et qu'on soit
cohérent sur notre intervention la
préfecture des Yvelines qui renforcent
des à présent la sécurité dans
l'ensemble des lieux publics je vous
rappelle qu'au moment où se déroule ce
journal les auteurs de la fusillade
n'ont toujours pas été arrêtés et c'est
aussi la peur de la Balme qui inquiète
les forces de l'ordre je précise que le
Conseil français du culte musulman a
condamné aujourd'hui je cite avec la
plus grande détermination l'acte barbare
contre la démocratie et la liberté de la
presse voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire en
ce triste mercredi soir toutes nos
pensées vont bien évidemment en famille
et aux proches des victimes je préfère
mourir debout que vivre à genoux nous
refermons cette première partie du
journal avec cette phrase de charme je
vous laisse découvrir à présent en
images l'actualité du jour dans le
département et je vous retrouverai
demain à 18h
8h30 ce matin à l'école du bois de
l'étang c'est le calme plat la mairie
multiplie les actions lettre du maire à
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem la ministre de
l'Éducation pétition et ce matin
villemorte on nous a reconnu 70% de
notre territoire est en géographie
prioritaire mais un Belkacem qui était
ministre de la Ville j'avais plaidé
auprès d'elle pour être que tous nos
quartiers de logements sociaux soient en
politique de la ville elle l'a reconnu
elle essaie et sa successeur et
aujourd'hui en tant que ministre
d'éducation nationale elle retire nos
écoles de la c'est complètement
incohérent cette sortie des réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire entraînera des
augmentes financement pour l'émission
éducatives et des moyens aux enseignants
on a besoin parce que les parents ils
sont ils ont pas tous les moyens des
autres villes
il y a des moments où il y a des parents
qui travaillent même pas alors pourquoi
ils vont nous enlever tous les aides
qu'on a déjà notre quartier le bois de
l'étang est connu pour être justement un
quartier difficile et je suis vraiment
ça m'a scotché quand j'ai appris que la
verrière allait être retirée de cette de
ces zones sensibles ça ça m'a ça m'a
vraiment étonné parce que il y a eu pas
mal de faits divers c'est ces dernières
années et juste ça c'est un dilan
10 heures place de l'Hôtel de Ville des
parents et des élus arrivent des
différents établissements du côté des
syndicats on se félicite de la
mobilisation près de 75% des enfants
sont absents le collège lui n'a
accueilli que 10% de ses effectifs on a
un collège qui a une spécificité
particulière puisqu'il est à cheval sur
deux communes la verrière et le Mesnil
avec des spécificités particulières une
mixité importante aussi bien au niveau
social que au niveau disparité des
enfants on a des bons résultats voilà
mais c'est très très fragile et on est
vraiment on est vraiment très très
inquiet pour la suite si on perd nos
moyens qui nous ont permis de remonter
le collège qui n'était pas dans cette
situation il y a encore une dizaine
d'années à 11h le rassemblement a défilé
dans les rues les actions vont se
poursuivre la pétition a pour le moment
rassemblée de 159 signatures les
enseignants du collège de Champaigne
sont appelés à faire grève demain
je pensais pas que du monde des ce matin
en ce premier jour des soldes pas besoin
d'attendre très longtemps pour croiser
deux roses acheteurs bonnes affaires en
main les restrictions là je suis sûr du
moins 60 sur un petit chenille un petit
gilet style collège un petit t-shirt
ambiance montagne et un petit gilet
collège donc voilà donc -60
habituellement ils arrivent plutôt vers
9h
ne c'est à 10h que ça commence à être
chaud
jusqu'à 18h on va dire donc là ça
commence bien comme ça la journée va
passer vite
l'ouverture des 8h30 ce matin a permis
aux clients de pouvoir essayer les
produits tant convoité avant l'arrivée
de la foule et de profiter ainsi des
réductions
à l'ouverture des magasins et
heureusement que ça s'ouvre à 8h30 parce
que ça me donne plus de courage après ça
part vite alors j'ai absolument voulu
venir à l'ouverture donc voilà bah toi
avant 50% c'est intéressant le premier
jour des soldats d'annonce la couleur
les commerçants sont confiants ils
espèrent augmenter leur chiffre
d'affaires de 40% un rendez-vous à ne
pas rater en cette période de crise
économique on se fasse aussi ou la météo
joue beaucoup là il fait froid donc les
gens vont s'équiper gros moto les pulls
etc cette année les soldes d'hiver
dureront 6 semaines au lieu de 5 vous
aurez jusqu'au 17 février pour en
profiter
vous avez constaté que les inconscient
parce qu'elle a pas répondu à des petits
gestes que vous lui a demandé maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
inconscient ça serait bien d'avoir de
l'aide
en espérant une victime est au sol elle
ne respire pas et est inconsciente une
situation à laquelle tout le monde peut
être un jour confronté le temps que les
secours arrivent connaître les gestes
qui sauvent est alors primordial
le temps d'une journée dans les locaux
de la Croix-Rouge à Chevreuse les
apprentis se forment à travers
différentes mises en situation parmi les
principaux gestes à connaître la
position latérale de sécurité la fête
laisse les victimes sur le dos et la
langue va retomber au fond de la gorge
et va empêcher la respiration donc le
simple fait de me le victime sur le côté
ça va le permettre de vomir s'il a
besoin de vomir et de respirer jusqu'à
ce que les secours arrive dans le relais
Camille passe aujourd'hui son diplôme de
premier secours civique de niveau 1
nécessaire pour valider sa formation de
coach sportifs
sont juste venus se former pour se
rassurer c'est de façon volontaire pour
porter les premiers secours parce que je
n'en ai aucune connaissance et qui m'est
arrivé certaines choses et je ne sais
pas quoi faire je panique à la fin de la
journée tout se verront remettre le
certificat officiel délivré par le
ministère de l'Intérieur également
valable en Europe pour une durée de 5
ans la formation d'un coup de 60 euros
s'adresse à tout le monde dès l'âge de
10 ans
une fois qui avait 82 ans si ma mémoire
est bonne sa femme était cardiaque et il
voulait à tout prix connaître le
fonctionnement d'un défibrillateur donc
il est venu se former j'ai trouvé ça
très courageux
dans les Yvelines 17 unités locales de
la Croix Rouge proposent cette formation
l'organisme forme environ 15% de la
population française encore loin de leur
objectif de 25%
nouvelle rétrospective en ce mois de mai
ce qui fait toujours débat c'est la
réforme des rythmes scolaires la
nouvelle mouture présentée par le
ministre de l'Éducation Benoît Hamon a
reçu un avis négatif du Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation et certaines
mairies n'hésitent pas à braver la loi
et décréter qu'elle ne mettront pas en
place la réforme en septembre c'est le
cas de la ville de Plaisir finalement la
réforme s'appliquera mais les temps
d'activité seront plus des temps de
garderie
manifestation sur l'aérodrome de
Saint-Cyr-l'École contre les nuisances
aériennes ils étaient une centaine
soutenue dans leur action par les mers
notamment de Saint-Cyr-l'École ou encore
de plaisir il réclame des plages de
silence le week-end et de nouvelles
trajectoires la Direction générale de
l'aviation civile devait réunir une
commission consultative avant l'été
culture maintenant mi-mai se tenait à
Paris la finale du trophée d'un pro
culture et diversité parmi les 5 villes
participantes les collégiens de Trappes
défendaient leurs communes pour la
quatrième année une finale marquée par
la présence inattendue du président de
la République François Hollande venu
saluer l'action du théâtre d'impro qui
permet la création tout autant que la
discipline le dépôt de bus du réseau
Fébus bloqué pendant deux semaines à
Versailles elle est conducteur dénonçait
leurs conditions de travail pas de
discussion avec leur direction mercredi
21 mai le tribunal administratif de
Versailles ordonnait l'arrêt du blocage
du dépôt de bus par les grévistes le
dialogues pourra reprendre en mai ce
sont les élections européennes dans les
Yvelines un peu plus de 45% des
électeurs se sont déplacés aux urnes des
élections marquées par une forte
progression du Front national à 17% qui
se positionne comme deuxième partie du
département derrière l'UMP 24%. le PS
réalise 11,89% des voix en 2009 le Parti
socialiste et la liste d'Harlem Désir
avaient totalisé 11,60% des suffrages
grands perdants de ces élections Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui dépasse les 7%
pour ce scrutin là où le parti réalisé
près de 20%, 5 ans auparavant à noter
sur notre secteur une forte poussée du
FN à Trappes qui devient le premier
parti de la ville pour ses élections ou
seulement 25% des électeurs se sont
pressés aux urnes
l'hôpital privé de l'Ouest parisien fait
peau neuve attrape l’établissement
inauguré sa nouvelle extension ainsi que
la rénovation de son ancien bâtiment des
travaux de près de trois ans qui
permettront d'améliorer son
accessibilité et sa capacité à répondre
aux besoins des patients
près d'un an après ce contrôle
d'identité auquel il s'était interposé
qui avait provoqué plusieurs nuits de
violence dans les rues de Trappes
Michael Kiri a été condamné par la cour
d'appel de Versailles à trois mois de
prison avec sursis enfin une piste de ce
qui a Élancourt peut-être la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines y
pense une partie de la population
riverains écologiste en fait des
cauchemars le projet en est pour
l'instant au stade de la réunion
publique dont la première s'est tenue le
3 juillet dans la commune entre
opposition et réalisme financier le
projet sera finalement gelé au mois de
novembre